the chimanimani mountains look like an
untouched paradise
but antonio governor knows better he is
once again on the trail of illegal gold
prospectors
usually the streams around here are
clear but not this one
so there must be an illegal mine
somewhere upstream
in the middle of mozambique's
chumanimani national reserve
his rangers detain every gold miner
don't you know this is a nature reserve
no i only arrived yesterday i heard
others were here
don't you know this isn't allowed
i didn't a friend told me i should come
so he didn't know either right right
where are the other mozambicans
the gold diggers are called gaimperos
the rangers see this group for the first
time and call the police
only repeat offenders face time in jail
because the national park wants to win
over the gold miners
when we find somebody for the first time
we try to educate them
we talk to them about the negative
impact of illegal gold mines
and we also tell them about alternatives
and opportunities
for example
but also about development projects in
agriculture
and nature conservation project
the gamperos are a serious problem for
the national park
thousands of people lost everything due
to cyclone edie in 2019
now they're looking for gold and
precious stones using the most
rudimentary methods
just to get an income as a result
forests are being cut down and toxic
mercury is contaminating the waters
so the national park is seeking to
provide alternative sources of income
gi batter ciabatta is one of the first
beneficiaries of a job creation scheme
he trained as a veterinarian and now
helps farmers look after their cattle
the park is working with a conservation
project called mars bio to create jobs
for people who live in the areas
bordering the park
before ciabatta became a vet he too was
a gold prospector
yes i used to do it too but then i began
to have doubts
and understand that you can't always be
a gold digger
the more i take out the less there is
until one day it's totally depleted
and if there's nothing left what should
i live on
that's why i started working as a vet
and it's been well worth the effort
since 2017 the park has created hundreds
of jobs in agriculture
everything from organic coffee growing
to sustainable beekeeping and livestock
farming
but for many gold is still more
appealing
new mines are always popping up this one
blocks an important elephant path on the
edge of the park
a team from the ministry of mineral
resources and energy is on site
last week police evicted some guy in
peras and burned down their camp
orbeti martini the ministry's inspector
general
wants to make sure the mine remains
closed
but at the same time he also wants to
make a deal with the miners
we want the people here to keep mining
gold but in an organized manner that
benefits
both them and the government the passage
in the association
to do this they need to form
cooperatives
we have a program that helps miners set
up their own cooperatives
we also teach them methods that help
them to work more effectively
and without having such a negative
impact on the environment
specifically ambient
to see what this can look like we head
to tsetsera
one of the five mining cooperatives in
manika province
and the only one in the buffer zone
bordering the park
any mozambican can become a member but
they have to hand over a third of their
proceeds as taxes and fees
the gold is mined and sold legally the
tunnels are safe
and the ministry has donated simple
tools
however some miners use highly toxic
mercury to bind gold dust from the mud
a board member in the cooperative el
esseo makumba
says it's the only way to stay
competitive
because illegal miners don't care about
environmental regulations so they can
push down the price
why are we as a cooperative left behind
well we have to work with the people we
have to register them
monitor the work pay taxes and
government fees
when there's a problem for example if
one of our members has an accident in a
mine
we have to take them to the hospital
so it's very difficult to compete with
the illegal minds
meanwhile antonio govini is meeting one
of the 15 beekeepers supported by the
park and by the conservation group mars
bio
he is unsure about the mining work in
setsera
the use of mercury is a serious
violation of the rules
but the mining cooperative has at least
prevented hundreds of illegal ganperos
from coming to the park to look for gold
[Music]
still governing doesn't want another
cooperative here
he prefers to talk about the success of
sustainable agriculture which he hopes
can be expanded
with agricultural projects of which
beekeeping is just one example
we have been able to reduce the negative
impact humans have on the environment by
almost half
for one thing we currently see that
deforestation is decreasing
oh this florida is
these successes are solely needed the
mine blocking the elephant path where
the police burned down the camp
is fully operational again by the very
next day
the guy imperials will not stop looking
for gold because they are poor
and need the money
if they stop us from digging here all
the people will starve to death
by mining we can at least buy some food
and pay school fees
school fees i cannot stress that enough
the illegal prospectors will surely
continue searching for gold
it's more dangerous than working in a
cooperative but also more lucrative